welcome back to uncensored with bjk now
the premier league is back i'm a west
ham supporter which means i spent the
opening weekend of the season being
steamrolled by big bloke from norway
elsewhere the focus was on that
perennial question of the modern game to
knee or not to me now the league says
it's ready to move on players will no
longer routinely take the knee before
games only it says at significant
moments well several clubs considered
the start of the season significant
enough uh players from west ham palace
spurs liverpool and arsenal all did it
anyway so the big question vacuous
virtual signaling or something that is
still a powerful stance against racism
on a major platform i'm joined now by a
legend uh
x england west ham bolton and knotts
county manager and many more uh the
legend that is sam allardyce who welcome
my friend welcome math thank you very
much
are you back taking the knee
i'm back taking the knee absolutely i
think but i think it is
time that it
moved on i think there's there's a time
when i didn't realize it was
two years or more since we first started
taking the knee but i'd have to say
what's coming out now
is the right way forward where
gradually they are doing it less and
less
and as the pfa
chief executive said it's an individual
choice now for me it is
an individual choice where if you
feel comfortable doing it do it and if
you don't you should be allowed not to i
think it's all about impact isn't it and
when you when you see i said it last
week when you see footballers doing it
and the people in the terraces are
clapping
those are the the people that don't need
to be taught about racism and i wonder i
said it last week man of mine dave
suggested this i wonder whether clubs
chairman
players should get out in the community
and use their fame and their success to
spread the word about anti-racism that
way rather than taking the name not
against it but i just wonder whether it
is what it was well there's a huge
amount of work done in the community
particularly your club by the way a very
very good community program west ham
indeed like you mean where they get out
in the movie whether they're doing it in
terms of
the racism side or not but every
player's contracted to do seven hours a
week not the players they ask them to do
seminars a week with with the schedule
but they all turn out all the well
most of the players turn out and of
course west ham the most popular player
who turned out most was mark noble he
was uh let's let's talk about the
beginning of the premiership season are
you missing it
yeah you miss it i mean it
you know it's your life it's your whole
life so when you're used to the pressure
when you're used to looking forward to
the start of the season working with the
players and and getting going you you
you do miss it you know so mrs allardyce
has had you all summer i know exactly
what happened i'd be getting too fed up
with me and want me to go back well you
see that might be the case never say
never if you stand up
it might be the case she is watching she
wrote she texted me
but apparently on a serious note uh your
phone starts ringing about november
december you're going to enjoy yourself
now and you're going to wait for trouble
on a serious note first question would
you go back
if it's the right club i think i would
yeah i'd miss it right they're right
they're right you miss it i think i've
still got
still got some years left in me and i
think that i've been having had over 12
months off since uh since west brom now
you know i i do i do miss that the
desire to get in amongst the players to
work with the players and to use my
experience to help a football club it's
no longer for me
going to take a football club like bald
wonders did and take them into europe or
or go go to newcastle and try and take
them to europe it's about going saving a
football club because that works that's
how people have labeled me ready sam i'm
quite happy with that
um and the bonuses that come with it
very quickly an overview of the the
start of the season this is my overview
west ham 106 passes in the first half
man city had about a thousand they look
unbeatable if i was eric vanta i mean
manchester united they start by losing
at home to brian the mystique of that
club nobody's talking about them being
being in the top four for me the
performance of the the saturday and i
hate to say it with spurs i think spurs
will be a major major force under
context
i thought that i watched that game as
well i thought that uh
the the the the comeback the shock of
the goal early doors
but you can see
um
conti's influence oh known him for a
long time met him
in juventus many years ago
came to west ham when he was national
team manager and that man really is
his way or no way
and whatever the tottenham players
thought about who they were or they
weren't
antonio conte will say it's my way lads
or
love for the road so he's got them fit
he's got them organized and there's some
good new players being bought by the
looks loads of questions who wins the
premiership
manchester city it gets relegated
um
[Music]
southampton i think nottingham forest
maybe maybe southampton this year
and whether whether it may be
bournemouth or fulham even though
they've started really well will depend
on
what they've recruited when the window
shuts bolton and fulham will be phoning
this man before christmas let's move on
to the qatar world cup uh this week
marks 100 days to the cadillac world cup
so much written and said uh former
germany captain phil um today says he
won't be
attending it due to the the country's
human rights record you of course manage
newcastle newcastle taken over
as we know by a saudi-backed public fund
what's your view on sports washington
live golf has come out there's money
being involved now what's your what's
your take on all that
money rules
across the world here
you know you know bring your money in
you can get in here i must say about the
european golf tour because i'm
passionate about this
golf with you know well you know live
golf the dp world tour is sponsored
do buy ports and that's saudi money so
you're right well you know so it's it's
money talks and money we'll talk in
sports with tennis and golf and football
at every single level of course and then
now they've got the world cup they will
want to make the biggest show on earth
of the world cup when it comes in
december of course i mean they've spent
so much money on the stadiums
which will be obsolete once they're
finished and
and they want to they want to show what
they can do that's what that's what
dubai started doing everybody else has
followed that and because of the wealth
of those countries they will continue to
do that i never thought i'd get a chance
to drop the boxing as well they have i
never thought i'd get you a chance to
ask you one of my heroes um six years
ago next month sat by england after 67
days a travesty in my humble opinion
thank you and i mean that genuinely
because i know what it meant to you i
know that you've opened up about the
toll it took on you because you are
england through and through um here's
the question you never thought that
you'd be asked when you watched the
semi-final when you watched the final
the nearest and greatest opportunity
this country has had for a long time
you'd have won it wouldn't you big sound
well i'd have to say yes to that but
that doesn't say that gareth has done a
fantastic job
he has but you know you always back
yourself when you when you got the job
when you've done the job and you waited
for it for so long then you would you
would back yourself from day one when i
walked into st george's park that would
be the ultimate goal
when you grow up football is your life
you make it to england manager just as a
mate what did it do to you when they
took it away
oh i think there's only family got me
through
the the
the family got me through the time the
dark times the dark period
the depression the
you know i didn't go on
tv and talk about it talk about it that
much like people i think should do today
i perhaps i should have heard about it
more but in the end the family family
got me through no matter and lots of
friends in football and then more
importantly later on steve parish
because he gave me my life back as a
football manager and i uh
enjoyed immensely my time with the with
crystal palace and steve parish and
showing everybody what i can still do
and that was get them get them out of
the relegation zone but england will
always always
stab me in the heart but there you go
you have to get over it
when you see england being successful is
it tinged with a little bit of regret
that could be me there's no danger about
that you know you know
in my opinion that should be me but it's
not so you know and to see that squad
and the quality of that squad as well
to think that could have been my
opportunity but uh you can't cry over
spilt milk and i guess in the end you go
well i did get to become the england
manager correct um and that meant that
my peers and my employers thought that i
was good enough for that what's next for
big sam waiting for the call one would
never know i mean there's a couple of
jobs abroad that i've turned down
because it's a bit late in my time of
life at 67 to go
packing my bags and moving away and
going abroad and going
that would have happened 10 years ago
thankfully i would have tried it but now
it will uh it will hopefully something
i'll turn up whether that might be in
the championship again who knows but
certainly certainly having another shot
um i've got a bit itchy again i've got a
bit anxious again like you mean because
the garden looks okay yeah and sammy
lee's
family is annoying yeah well yes i mean
somebody's probably more desperate than
i am you know i mean because we have a
great partnership there listen you're
one of football's great men personally i
thought it was gutting when you lost
that england job but everybody knows
they're good you're and i've absolutely
no doubt before december big sam will be
back saying yeah well we'll do our best
we'll block up the defense and we'll hit
some goals and we'll do it i had a great
four years at your club so well
is not doing bad is he not bad at all
listen absolutely brilliant sam thank
you very much
you